hallo mein name ist flughafen meine
lieben freunde dieses t shirt hier gibt
es zu kaufen
das t shirt gibt es zwar schon seit drei
jahren
aber es ist trotzdem ein cooles t shirt
und damit herzlich willkommen wir heute
meine damen und herren zu einem neuen
video auf einem kanal ihr seht es
bereits im titel erkennst du den youtube
wir machen heute zwei quiz und zwar
einmal youtuber erkennen anhand ihrer
stimme und anhand ihres mundes ja ich
würde sagen gefahren direkt an ich kenne
ich keine stimme aber die stimme
[Musik]
hätte ich hätte ich drauf kommen können
wir machen das ganze abwechselnd also
für muss sich ein youtube anhand seiner
stimme erkennen jetzt anhand seines
mundes ich habe hier absolut keine
ahnung ich weiß es nicht vielleicht
julians blog
oder so es ist turbo bin ich ganz
ehrlich schaue ich die videos nicht den
hätte ich jetzt nie an seinem mund
erkannt also bisher läuft so nicht so
gut aber wir machen nun weiter mit der
nächsten stimmen erkennungs youtuber
sache genauso es gibt sehr viele leute
die ihr halt schon mal vorgeschlagen
haben so zu zocken oder das live stream
und mit einem kopfball grund glaube ich
mit warum nicht hin von gewittern
warum du nicht so oder so bei gott ich
dachte safe dass wir jetzt vielleicht
irgendein streamer oder so den ich nicht
erkannt habe oder irgendwie sowas nicht
als auch allgemein gar nicht kenne aber
oh mein gott tim wenn du das hier siehst
ich habe rasiert machen wir nun dann
allerdings wieder weiter mit einem mund
und zwar ist das hier würde ich sagen
ich hab' ich habe absolut keine ahnung
absolut keinen plan es ist partie vor
preis
nach der sonnenkraft
hier wird jeder bad außer ich
ich bin 23 und habe keinen bart sind
immer dieselben sprüche ja jeder braucht
auch laster kein alkohol lautet für
lautet mein gott ey das bevor es jetzt
aufgelöst wird es ist so richtig ich
weiß nicht ob das bei euch genauso ist
aber ich höre die stimme und ich kann
sie direkt ich kenne die stimme wisst
ihr aber dann wenn man so ja ich glaub
ihr wisst was ich meine dass die
brauerei so johannes zu stellen laut ok
ok so krass bin ich bisher eigentlich
doch nicht das heißt wir machen direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten mund dass es
entweder schenks oder gurken sohn
ich sage allerdings gurken sohn
ich glaub das ist dran machen weil er
die gefühle weiter mit der nächsten
stimme eines youtube hätte ich mich auf
keinen fall
[Musik]
falls du das hier gerade das mit der
stimme ist so schwierig auch dass hier
wieder ich habe absolut keine ahnung ich
habe auf den ersten blick gedacht dass
ich das vielleicht sogar wäre aber es
ist es ist es ist ja mein gott das ist
aber ein altes foto von das video ist
von ford einem halben jahr
das ist aber das ist aber ein so altes
foto hatte harry die verquollenen augen
geschlossen
nicole walter sein dumbledores link im
nasen voldemorts schlange aber wundert
sich und seinen beiden hasserfüllt an
versuchte weiter gierig an seinem umfeld
lecken dass herr marathon an dem harry
kupfer viel hinten ja schlug sechs
männer die stimme würde ich bei 3000
meter gegen den wind erkennen machen
allerdings weiter mit dem
[Musik]
tja wer könnte das bloß sein ich würde
mal tippen dass das kathi als wenn da
gar nicht mehr als der mond
rausgeschnitten wäre ich das sogar
erkannt
ich halte meine lieblings youtube in
wann fällt übrigens zu katja kramer wird
sandra und ich haben sie angefragt ob
sie in einer folge dem konto bei unseren
podcast mit dabei sein will und sie hat
abgesagt das management hat uns
ignoriert
und ja das mal dazu am rande da waren
wir sehr sehr traurig machen allerdings
weiter mit der nächsten stimme und sagte
wahrscheinlich jeder mann hat sich zu
viele nudeln zum abendessen macht eine
zu kleine portionen und noch mal
aufzuhören am nächsten tag dazu schreibe
ich mir eine woche lang alles auf nichts
mit
es wird und wie viel geld ich eigentlich
lebensmittel ab 12 warte ich zeige euch
das noch mal
ich zeige euch das noch mal es klang ein
zu eins wie peace mit achtet jetzt viele
nudeln zum abendessen macht es eine zu
kleine portionen und nochmal aufzuwärmen
eins zu eins mit aber gut freuen ich
würde sagen wir machen weiter mit dem
nächsten mund und ich würde sagen dass
es kuchen tv das allein weder kuchen tv
oder oder uns ein paar des tv würde ich
sagen aber er kuchen tvs ist kuchen tv
das erkennt man einfach komisch
hintergrund habe ich schon geschafft in
deutschland
der markante stimme machen allerdings
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten mund ich
habe auch hier wieder absolut keine
ahnung ich finde gerade bei den bad
unfassbar
herr newstime 100 prozent oder prozesses
newstime ich erkenne es immer erst an
der statur oder wie die dann sitzen oder
keine ahnung war es allerdings nun
weiter mit einer stimme ist dieser
wettbewerb zwischen einem riesigen
entertainment-konzern aus indien und
einem kleinen schwedischen jung und
kamera ausgetragen wird
klingt ein lächeln ja und das mag ich
eigentlich so ein youtube will dass man
doch juristisch wenn man die sprache
kann jeden content in ich weiß nicht ob
ich bisher gut oder schlecht
ich glaube ich bin zum
durchschnittlichen mittelfeld nun zur
abwechslung dann allerdings wieder ein
mund ich habe auch hier absolut keine
ahnung ist es wieder eine person mit
bart beziehungsweise mit zum mit seinem
halben bad mehr oder weniger ich etwas
absolut ich sagen es ist das hätte ich
hat
das gleiche mikro wie ich finde es so
schade dass ich halt will man ihr wisst
nicht was gerade bei uns abgeht und ja
hier macht sich natürlich dann gedanken
über gott was ist passiert und ich
möchte einfach dieses video drehen und
das ist sofort zu stoppen
absolut keinen plan verliert
hä
da mal nicht so blöd ja also ich meine
ja ich schaue sehr sehr sehr sehr wenig
deutschsprachige videos aber dass ich
mich zu wenig auskennen alter das ist ja
peinlich machen wir von daher hier
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten mund ich
habe auch hier wieder jetzt noch keine
ahnung aber vielleicht wenn man das
gesamtbild sieht habe ich auch noch
keine ahnung ich weiß es nicht
niamey wäre ich in meinem leben nicht
drauf gekommen
ich meine ihr könnt mir auch mal gerne
in die kommentare schreiben hey von
wegen luca wie consten darauf nicht
kommen das erkennt man auch an dem und
die merkmale oder ihr könnt ja selbst
einfach mal mit raten in den kommentaren
aber ich schäme mich wirklich dieses
video hier gerade aufzunehmen mich ist
dass gerade so wie wenn man vorne vor
der klasse steht und dann muss etwas vor
recht und man kriegt einfach nicht hin
dass hier weiß ich allerdings ist es
rieso hundertprozentig spätestens jetzt
an dem blauen haaren erkennt man dass
safe und das ist riesig so dass man
richtig professionelles bild hier vom
web video preis deutschland wir sehen
schon die animation das heißt die
nächsten münder kommen ms sind zwei
leute auf diesem kanal ich habe hier
keine ahnung ich den tvs ist es ist das
dachte erst 80
aber dann dachte ich die sind zu dritt
und die gibt es eigentlich nicht mehr
dann dachte ich es sei dieser simple
message oder simple economics oder keine
ahnung was und ich glaube ich jeder
kennt diesen kanal vom lernen für mathe
arbeiten noch von früher die erklären
einem so formeln und rechnungen in
therapie
aber das ist wintv ist all das habe ich
erst auf dem letzten drücker erraten
dass hier ist der nächste mund bzw
vielleicht auch schon der letzte mund
weil das video hier geht nicht mehr so
lange die sache ist ich habe auch hier
absolut keine ahnung wer das sein könnte
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es nicht
oh mein gott ich habe hier bei der szene
habe ich kurz gedacht es ist
ich muss hat den namen vergessen excel
95 leuchtet wenn ihr euch das hier
anschaut ja vielleicht auch nicht es war
aber auf jeden fall user gehen auf jeden
fall auch die grüße raus hier ist es
allerdings jetzt auch schon vorbei also
wenn ihr ein youtuber erkannt habt
dann herzlichen glückwunsch ich habe
auch ein paar erkannt allerdings noch
sehr viele nichts fällt das video
allerdings auch gefahr da würde ich mich
sehr sehr wohl bei einem daumen hoch von
euch unter dem video hier freuen
schreibt er wie bereits gesagt gerne
unten in die kommentare wenn ihr alles
erraten konnte und wo ihr wirklich auch
eure zweifel hatte beziehungsweise wo
ihr ein bisschen am verzweifeln wenn
euch das video dennoch gefallen hatte
ich habe schon gesagt dass ihr gerne dem
video einen daumen hoch geben könnte ja
das könnte ich noch so sagen abonniert
gern main kanal
das ist kostenlos dadurch verpasst ihr
keine videos mehr wenn ihr schon aber
nett seid könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken
es ist ziemlich heiß wenn denn dann wenn
ich ein video hochladen bekommt die
direkte benachrichtigung und können
direkt versuchen coolen kommentar zu
schreiben und ob kommen zu werden keine
ahnung was ich bin cool steve dann hab
ich auch schon gesagt ne schon lange im
lukasz ob ich wieder gefunden im schrank
finde ich sehr entspannt
[Musik]
euro